welcome back this is Sky News in just a
moment the Press preview a first look at
what's on the front pages as they arrive
but first our top stories two weeks
before the World Cup starts qatar's
foreign minister has told us that
criticism over the country's treatment
of Migrant workers and LGBT plus rights
had a sense of arrogance
Rishi sunak has arrived in Egypt to
attend [ __ ] 27 where the issue of
compensating vulnerable countries for
the damaged climate change of climate
change will be discussed for the first
time and the prime minister is facing
questions here over his appointment of
Sir Gavin Williamson to the cabinet
after he sent abusive messages to the
conservative former Chief whip
[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview of
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the economics correspondent advert
spectator Kate Andrews and the political
editor of the Daily Mirror John Stevens
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now well the
telegraph leads with a report that
Britain has opened the door to paying
climate change reparations to developing
countries by supporting talks on the
issue at cop27
the US UK Canada and Australia have
fallen billions of dollars short of
their fair share of climate funding for
developing countries that reporting the
guardian
the front of the express says senior
conservatives
urged Rishi sunak to stick to the
pensions triple lock as a matter of
principle
on the front of the times there's a
report that billions of pounds of
government spending in Britain is being
classified as a foreign aid as ministers
grapple with the small boats crisis and
war in Ukraine
the Metro reports that a boy has died as
fireworks were launched down the street
their headline bonfire night of mayhem
according to the Sun the Prime Minister
has hit out at MP Matt Hancock for going
on TV show I'm a celebrity
and the Daily Star also has a story
about Matt Hancock and his appearance on
the reality show
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Kate Andrews and John Stevens good
evening to you both welcome uh let's
start with the telegraph the front page
of the Telegraph and uh wish you soon at
cop 27 in charmele Sheikh he has now
arrived um what do you think he has on
his to-do list Kate
well he's going to want to recommit to
the pledges made at carb 26 which was uh
from Boris Johnson's perspective and of
course where she seen that was a main
character a key player in Boris
Johnson's cabinet a very big moment for
the UK and he's going to want to make
sure that he doubles down on the
commitments that he made during the
leadership campaign to achieving those
Net Zero targets but what's interesting
on the front page of the telegraph is
that something that Ed miliband was
calling for this morning on the Sunday
news round which a lot of people were
saying well you know that's a bit
radical Rishi CNAC is going to engage
with at cop26 and that is uh mainly
Pakistan's call um for reparations for
countries that are suffering from
damages due to climate change already
countries like Bangladesh and the
Maldives are looking for compensation
now this is very very early days and
Rishi sinak has agreed to take part in
last minute conversations about
reparations but by no means is
committing to anything and given another
story we're going to talk about this
evening on the front page of the
Guardian
um it's very easy to say in in theory
that you're you're going to provide
these kinds of funds it's very different
in practice so we're not far down this
road but interesting once again the
labor party is calling for more spending
something we've seen over the past
couple months the conservative party
starts by saying no no that's ridiculous
and then ends up in discussion or
actually implementing the policy
reparations are being on the agenda
though certainly and the papers saying
that number 10 could be forced to pay
out to poor countries hit by global
warming disasters John
I don't think they're going to be forced
to do it I think quite clearly as we
know a lot of these Summits lots of
things get promised and they don't
necessarily end up happening we saw that
at [ __ ] 26 we know that some of the
things that were promised back then
haven't actually happened in the last 12
months but you can see why a lot of
these countries are unhappy they feel
that they are due some money from
countries that have got very wealthy
from using uh carbon emissions that you
know
countries that managed to become very
developed they've done very well out of
creating all of these emissions and then
there are a lot of spaces in the world
which are less developed which are
struggling with the consequences I think
in reality rather than just seeing this
as reparations money going from rich
countries to poor countries to kind of
pay off the debt of the things they've
done in the past what you're more likely
going to see is UK committing to do more
to help these countries adjust to uh
climate change so doing things places
like the Maldives how can they cope with
flooding we know that Pakistan a third
of the country was underwater because of
floods earlier this year we know the UK
already gives a lot of Aid money to
Pakistan could some of that be used and
look at how communities can cope with
changes in climate change and another
way that we spend money already at the
moment is helping countries transition
from using kind of uh dirty old fuels at
the moment into bringing in more in a
Green Solutions so we obviously have
changed in this country to using a lot
of wind power things like solar and so
that's one of the ways that we already
spend money is helping countries that
are already polluting a lot at the
moment moving towards Greener Solutions
so I think that's probably more likely
rather than us just kind of saying oh no
we're very sorry for what we've done in
the past and giving over a big check to
some of these countries but Kate the the
guardian tells us that the US UK Canada
and Australia have fallen billions of
dollars short of their fair share of
climate funding for developing countries
uh this comes in a new assessment by
report entitled carbon brief and we find
out that which countries pledge to
provide a hundred billion US Dollars
that's 88 billion pounds a year by 2020
and this target has been missed
mm-hmm so this is a really good example
of how you know making lofty promises
does not always uh pan out in in actual
policy or uh to put even more bluntly
cash uh being dished out where it's
supposed to go so the so-called fair
share climate fund for developing
countries uh which is supposed to be
helping them with this transition
um the the money that's supposed to be
put into it by the US the UK Canada and
Australia has not been met now it should
be noted that the UK has come quite
close to doing so
um but it still fell 1.4 billion dollars
short
um not a small chunk of change and it
has missed this deadline that it was
supposed to reach two years ago so you
know I've actually been speaking to
quite a few climate activists who are
very excited about cult 26 who are
either at cop27 and and feeling a bit
dispirited or decided not to go at all
and I think there's a growing sense that
you know when you actually put the facts
in front of these world leaders and when
you actually explain what has or has not
been met uh you know you you gets a
little bit more uncomfortable and that
it's all good and well to get people
together to discuss all of their dreams
and hopes and Ambitions for the future
but if we're not actually delivering on
the promises that we've already made and
the commitments we were supposed to
reach several years ago uh you know it
means that people aren't going to be
especially excited or optimistic about
what can be achieved in the future
um and and so I think there's going to
be real pressure on a cop 27 to show how
leaders and countries are actually going
to commit to what they've already
promised let alone the new promises that
might be made there onto the express and
talking about the triple lock that
senior Tories are urging the the prime
minister to stick to the promises made
and on the the trip a lot for pensions
the pledge
yeah so this is something that Tories
promised in their 2019 election
Manifesto what the triple lock means is
that pensions increase the state pension
increases every year and it goes up
either by inflation average earnings or
2.5 whichever of those three figures is
the highest and this is something that
the Tories have been saying that they
are considering dropping it's kind of
been an on off on off on off thing uh
over the last few weeks there was one
point where Liz trust said that she was
thinking of getting rid of it and then
she said she was going to do it and then
we had Rishi sunak come in and he said
that he's thinking about getting rid of
it and it's just one of these other
things that we're waiting now for the
Autumn statement on November the 17th to
see if the government do stick to their
promise or not and we know that there's
a massive black hole in the country's
finances we've done a discussion about
why that is and whether a lot of that is
due to Liz trust but I think this is
gonna be really hard hard for the
government if they start ripping up
things that they were quite clear in
their Prejudice to people at the last
election they were going to do if they
separate them now I think that would be
tricky if they go into the next general
election will say well how can we trust
anything you say when you haven't been
able to deliver lots of things in your
last Manifesto and this is really going
to be tricky for the government if they
do actually go ahead and get rid of it
because we know that pensioners are some
of the people who are most likely to
vote a lot of those people do go out to
polling stations and have their stay and
I think if they feel that they've been
betrayed by the government that they've
got promised one thing and then they
didn't actually get up end up doing it
then a lot of these people might think
well hang on a bit while I vote for them
maybe I'll just stay at home yeah the
article is warning that three
conservative ex ministers are fearing
that the party risks losing its vital
gray vote Kate
well Jones summed up the politics there
brilliantly that if you break Manifesto
promise it's very difficult to go back
to voters and say I promise to keep my
word and of course the people that this
is going to affect our
um you know not all of course but um
primarily where the Tory party is
looking for to get their votes to win
elections uh the difficulty about the
triple lock is that it's very expensive
and it contributes to intergenerational
unfairness and actually after the
financial crash and throughout the 2010s
you saw the state pension go up faster
sometimes than than wages were so there
was a sense that pensioners were better
off during that difficult time now of
course if it doesn't rise with inflation
the opposite argument will be made but
it's it's a very expensive policy and
whilst roughly 20 percent of pensioners
are thought to be on the poverty line
and they're vulnerable and they
absolutely need the support closer to 30
percent of pensioners are thought to be
in millionaire households and so I think
it's becoming clearer and clearer that
this blanket subsidy is not necessarily
the right one because we are topping up
people who really don't need the money
and perhaps not giving enough attention
to those who really do need the support
be very interesting to see whether the
triple lock is kept or not Kate and John
for the moment thank you we are going to
take a break coming up the PM stands by
Sir Gavin Williamson despite his rude
WhatsApp messages all that when we come
back
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me the economics
correspondent at The Spectator Kate
Andrews and the political editor of the
Daily Mirror John Stevens let us have a
look at the Metro now and this piece uh
looking at the fact that the prime
minister is continuing thus far to Back
Sir Gavin Williamson John
yeah this is a really tricky one for
Richard sunax so some text messages has
come out well I think they're actually
WhatsApp messages that were exchanged
between Gavin Williamson and Wendy
Morton who was the chief whip under Liz
truss and Gavin Williamson seems to have
really taken an issue with the fact that
he wasn't invited to go to the Queen's
Funeral Center barrage of messages to
Wendy Morton some of them slightly
sweary some of them seeming slightly
threatening to her and we find out now
that uh Richardson was made aware of
this before he did his reshuffle when he
became prime minister Jake Berry you had
been chair of the toy party warned where
she said that there had been a complaint
against it about these messages the cchq
which is the Tory head office were
looking into Gavin Williamson and he
went ahead anyway and appointed him to a
role in government and he attends
cabinet uh although it's his role in
cabinet is slightly mysterious he's a
minister without portfolio when you ask
number 10 what on Earth that means what
are his responsibilities they're not
really able to tell you what he's doing
and I think
coming off the back of the rail we had
last week with the Home Secretary Sue
Ella Braven and questions over why on
Earth he'd made her home secretary after
she'd been sat just six days earlier I
think just raises questions about what
she's doing next judgment and Weiner did
he pick these people when he put them in
the cabinet we know that Gavin
Williamson was sat under Theresa May
because he was accused of leaking
national security stuff we know under
Boris Johnson he got rid of him after he
seemed to make a barge of exams during
covid so it just seems really surprising
that Richardson had to try him for a
third time and surprise surprise it
seems to be going well okay do you agree
that this calls into question that the
prime minister's judgment
I think it's more a reminder that this
government uh this cabinet in particular
are bits and Bobs of the Tory Barty
being meshed together in order to bring
together what is increasingly a
fractured party Gavin Williamson has a
long-term reputation being the wheeler
and dealer behind the scenes he played a
very large role in getting MPS over the
line when Boris Johnson uh ran uh for
leader in 2019
um and he is a faction of the Tory party
that Rishi sunak has to keep on side
there's no doubt that the messages are
aggressive and I think from everything
we know about Rishi CNAC in the way that
he uh presents himself and usually
communicates this is a tricky situation
for him and you know it's telling that
Oliver Dowden has come out and said uh
the the cabinet secretary has come out
and said look we you know he was aware
that there was some disgruntlement uh
with the former Chief Whip and Gavin
Williamson was one of those MPS he Rishi
Cena is clearly trying to keep as much
distance as he can from this but it is
just a reminder between Gavin Williamson
and Sue Ella Braverman that Rishi sunak
had to make some compromises in order to
be in the position he's in now this was
not his dream cabinet it's the one he
had to put together to try to you know
get things working again and to try to
tackle the huge economic crisis ahead of
us
let's finally finish off with the um
Sana and these are claims that the prime
minister is is not too pleased with with
Matt Hancock and his appearance in the
jungle
John
yeah I just think the complete contrast
on these two stories Gavin Williamson
and Matt Hancock one of them's off in
the jungle I think a lot of people are
mad about that particularly voters in
his constituency but we'll see that
feels able to mouth off on this and say
oh isn't it awful what he's doing he's
not serving his constituents
be it on the issue of Gavin Williamson
we've not really heard anything from Mrs
unic at all and I think that you look at
the two sins that yeah I'm no big fan of
what Matt Hancock sing in the jungle I
think it is calling to be doing that
well Parliament is sitting but you
compare that with what uh Gavin
Williamson's accused of and he's not
only not criticizing governments and
he's still got him in his cabinet okay
your thoughts in 20 seconds
I think this this we need all MPS to
show up to work uh we have some really
difficult times ahead you know the bank
of England just forecast a two-year
recession and I think the prime minister
is quite right to take in as somebody
who's flying off to the Australian
jungle to go on reality TV Kate and John
thank you so much for taking us through
the papers we'll see you in the next
hour thank you